a never-before-seen portrait of princess
diana is now on display at kensington
palace
and no surprise here she looks stunning
in the black and white photo the late
princess who was 27 at the time looks
away from the camera diana wears a
one-shoulder gown and diamond earrings
while sporting her signature feathered
hair the portrait which is now part of
the new exhibition life through a royal
lens was taken by renowned photographer
david bailey in 1988 at the princess of
wales home kensington palace the image
which was shot nine years before diana's
death was originally commissioned for
the national portrait gallery but bayley
decided to keep it in his personal
archives until now
and diana's photograph is reminding fans
of similar picks the ones kate middleton
took for her 40th birthday in january
photos that show the duchess of
cambridge paying tribute to her late
mother-in-law that's really what matters
to me kate looks flawless showing off
jewelry that once belonged to princess
die specifically diamond and pearl drop
earrings and a white ruffled dress by
alexander mcqueen we're seeing the
duchess in a very different light i
think there is a new confidence about
her i think that comes with age she is
now 40 she is very confident poised
self-assured woman and with a great
sense of humor a lot of talent some of
which we're only just learning about and
while kate's dedication to giving back
certainly pays homage to her late
mother-in-law the duchess is also
working hard to create a unique lane of
her own i think one of the great
successes of the duchess of cambridge is
that she hasn't tried to carry on
diana's legacy she hasn't tried to fill
those
shoes which are of course impossible to
fill what kate's done and i think what
her greatest success has been is to
carve her own role for herself within
the royal family i mean she inherits the
title the princess of wales no one has
had that title since diana um but i
think where kate has been so clever is
to
create
her own
prototype of the princess of wales
through the work that she and william do
putting the spotlight on on those who
don't have a voice she is of course
continuing diana's legacy it's important
to her it's of course hugely important
to william
but what kate's doing is putting her own
stamp onto that title which she will one
day inherit and i think now we are
seeing the seeds that have been sewn we
are seeing the work that she's put 10
years into now coming to fruition and
it's work that really is making a
difference
[Music]
[Music]